I love it when something happens that's
outrageous and then you hear like a
super understated response to it and it
is leaked but in a conversation between
the Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and French President Emmanuel
macron Netanyahu admitted to the French
president that he is quote sceptical of
Donald Trump's israeli-palestinian peace
efforts well really what made you so
skeptical been any reasonable person
would be skeptical of Trump's efforts to
solve the israeli-palestinian conflict
his peace efforts have consisted of
saying he's going to send his son-in-law
Jared Kushner to the region to negotiate
peace which is completely laughable and
one of his first moves was to appoint
David Friedman to be the US ambassador
to Israel who unilaterally wanted to
move the US embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem which if you understand the
politics of the region you know would be
a total impediment to the peace process
and is a supporter of more Israeli
settlement which is like such an
unhinged extreme position that it is a
total non-starter if you're trying to
get closer to peace not to mention that
Trump has no clue about the
israeli-palestinian conflict there there
may not be a single issue on which
Donald Trump is less informed than the
israeli-palestinian conflict and also
reportedly from this conversation
between the French president and the
Israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu reportedly said the
palestinian issue is complicated and
McCrone agreed but replied you're making
it more complicated by building
settlements and I say good for McCrone
for mentioning that the continued
building of settlements has to stop it's
an impediment to peace and I know some
people who watch the show liked to call
me a Zionist shill of course they have
no clue whatsoever what that even means
but I've been abundantly clear that the
settlements must stop Benjamin Netanyahu
is also an impediment to peace there is
no reasonable argument for the continued
building of Israeli settlement and I've
said before yet if you're going to
ultimately negotiate israeli-palestinian
peace some of the bigger existing
settlements may have to be negotiated as
part of meaningful land swaps
you can't keep building and Benjamin
Netanyahu is right to be skeptical of
Trump's efforts for peace but everybody
should be skeptical about Benjamin
Netanyahu's efforts for
israeli-palestinian peace Palestinians
are going to have to make concessions
I've said it before there is absolutely
no doubt about it to even get this
process going but that's not going to
happen with Benjamin Netanyahu in power
who is aligned with extreme right-wing
religious elements in Israel and also
quite frankly benefits from not having
peace much of his reelection was
catalyzed by the idea that it's
dangerous were not closer to peace and
thus you need him to protect you if you
actually make progress towards peace the
need for a Netanyahu like figure is
diminished so you know I applaud
Emmanuel macron here I applaud Benjamin
Netanyahu for his skepticism Trump has
no place whatsoever in this conversation
but there's also it's not just Trump
that's an item into peace well obviously
this would be such a big undertaking and
it's something that if American
presidents in the past have attempted
they certainly have not been able to
succeed in doing builder Lyndon made
some progress right yeah and you know do
you think about Jimmy Carter with Egypt
and Israel as well but just saying that
you're going to send off Jared Kushner
to deal with it is more insulting than
anything else it doesn't make any
progress it sort of it confirms that
number one Trump doesn't know how
complex the situation is but it's also
kind of patronizing to say hey it's been
decades and decades and there's been
steps forward and steps back and
complications and simplifications and
armed conflicts and death and whatever
and Jared Kushner is going to just show
up and be able to solve the thing it's
really patronizing to the people that
have been working in some cases their
entire lives on the issue of the
israeli-palestinian conflict it's just
pathetic and Trump has no role to play
in my view on this and for Kushner it's
just one thing on his agenda he has five
or six other tasks he's managing like
everything at the White House and
possibly soon will be losing his
security clearance as well which will
certainly make these negotiations all
the more difficult for wonderboy to
participate in